are you able to create motion design  that you see in your head or do you  struggle with turning Vision into  reality you may think that you need to  attend art school or that searching  YouTube for countless hours will teach  you what you need to know but you don't  what you need is a mentorship and  training program built for aspiring  motion designers just like you and it's  called stylecraft my name is Cameron I'm  a pro motion designer with over 20 years  of experience I didn't go to art school  and I didn't learn from YouTube I spent  two decades learning how to become a pro  motion designer and I turned this  knowledge into stylecraft this isn't an  online course that just teaches you how  to push buttons stylecraft is an Engaged  Paradigm shifting mentorship program  that will teach you how to master  cinematic motion design join today and  find out what it feels like to unleash  Unstoppable Talent